- I love to be with
boys.
Of course, because I'm boy crazy
and I like to go crazy
and I like to party.
(upbeat music)
- [Host] The R word hurts my feelings.
- I gotta shirt right here.
It's called "let's end the R word"
because it's not cool to use it.
Don't use it at all.
Let's end bullies for good.
- We don't want to hear that word.
Take that word out of your
mouth and change it to respect.
- Just don't use the R
word in front of my face.
It's not okay to say this.
- Or don't say it at all.
- Yeah.
- And keep your mouth shut
and mind your own business.
- Yeah, it is not okay to say things
with kids with Down Syndrome.
Well, I would say just go and say hello.
It could be the start of
a beautiful friendship.
- It doesn't bother me too much.
But when, like, a friend
drives you somewhere
and they use cursing words,
that sometimes can get out.
I think people should ban that word.
And instead of saying that R word,
have the R word be respect.
- [Host] I am in a relationship.
- Being in a relationship with
my friends is pretty cool.
I'm disagreeing, because
I had lots of exes
and sometimes I want
to myself being single.
- [Matthew] The reason why
I picked somewhat agree
is because I've found my love
in someone that I care about.
And I'm really happy for that.
But sometimes it's hard to
keep my girlfriend happy.
- [Host] Why is it hard to keep her happy?
- Because sometimes she could be like,
why does she get angry?
She's usually hungry.
- [Sean] For me personally,
I do have a girlfriend.
But for all girlfriends out there,
be happy to have what you want,
because we are here
to have
great guys
to be in great in
relationship with ladies.
But ladies, it's really tough right now.
But
for me,
I love my girlfriend.
- [Host] I earn my own money.
Wow.
- [Kennedy] I wanted to earn my own money.
That's why I got a job.
The owner of the coffee
shop really likes me,
and I get my my own interview
and I got my own job to
make drinks and food.
And ever since I dated him,
it makes my heart very happy
to see him grow.
- It's very rewarding
to see what she does.
And it makes me proud.
- I earn my own money to be independently.
Like to live on your own.
And I make T-shirts!
- I do earn
my
money.
I work hard.
I want to be a billionaire
and a millionaire.
As a woman, as Down syndrome as myself,
I do make my money.
I wrote my book and I do public speaking.
And then I've been doing a
TV show called Born This Way.
I worked really hard to be on the top,
and that's what I am.
And I am very, very
successful career woman.
And I make the way and I
go big and I don't go home
and I follow my dream.
- [Matthew] That's true.
Us kids with special needs
have dreams to follow.
No matter what dream it is,
do what you can do the best.
Don't let anyone take you down.
I love earning my own money.
It feels great to know
that I did a good job
of working.
It makes me feel happy
that I did a great job.
Even though I have Down syndrome
I earned that money
because I earned respect.
So people out there who
think we can't do it,
we can!
And we're powerful, strong,
and we can do anything
we put our minds to.
- [Host] Grace, do you wanna
share, "I earn my own money"?
- [Sean] She's doing this.
- She's like making some money.
Making some money.
- Yeah, that helps.
- Yeah.
- There you go.
I can help you out.
- [Host] I want to have children.
- [Matthew] I don't want
to have a kid just yet.
Maybe when I feel that
it's the right time,
if I want to have a kid.
I will.
But it's also hard to take care of them
because of what I have.
And its hard for me to
get up in the morning,
prepare a lunch for my kids, and all that.
It's hard.
So I kinda want to get to know
who I am right now and learn.
- I would love to have children
because I love children!
They're a lot of fun to play with, like,
to play around with them.
Do anything with them.
And I would love to have
kids to pay attention,
to cuddle, because we're
all here to have fun.
- I like babies a lot.
It's a lot of responsibility
to take care of a child.
So, I'm going to be a
great mother and teach them
to have manners and great and having fun
and explore their education.
I just came over here to agree.
I do want to have children.
I do want to give my kid a life.
And I want to raise them as my own.
But I do not want to depend on my mom
to raise my child by herself.
I do want have kids because
I want to give them the life
that my mother gave me.
- [Host] I can take care of myself.
- [Megan] Well, I do
would take care of myself.
I'm really good at cooking
and cleaning after myself.
Sometimes I'm not very good
by keeping my room clean sometimes.
But I work on towards that.
I do get independent.
I am like an independent woman.
I like to be with my friends.
I love to be with boys, of
course, because I'm boy crazy.
And I like to go crazy
and I like to party.
- [Ranjani] I'm very confident
and good at putting on clothes.
And do some groceries.
Take care of yourself, like self caring,
and helping people out
and make people laugh
and entertained from my comedy.
Yeah.
I'm going to be stand up comedian.
- [Host] Oh, so you have jokes?
- Yes, I do.
(chuckles)
- [Matthew] I can take care of myself.
- We need to move.
Come this way.
- Mommy!
- Say "I".
- Want.
- What?
- Help
bath.
- She needs help with her bath.
- [Host] Oh, got it.
- Thank you, mommy.
- [Host] Good job, thank you.
I love how I look.
- [Matthew] The reason
why I say strongly agree
is because I love the way I look.
I don't care what I look like.
I know what I like.
And I'm very happy for that.
And I don't care what people think of me.
I know I'm the best,
because I love my body.
- I am
beautiful,
I'm
unique
and I am beautiful.
And I am also an independent women.
- I love the way I look because I am
gorgeous.
I am beautiful and strong
and fearless because I'm
fierce.
- [Ranjani] For me, staying
beautiful and being strong
and confident,
you get some boost of
your looks in the mirror
and feel confident of who you are.
- [Sean] Well, I love my
look and my personality
like
greatness
personality
because
I am who I am.
But I love myself.
I do.
But for me, it's really
cool to be with my friends
it's here right now with me.
It's these friends I have right now.
Because I feel so great,
because I feel so powerful.
Look at these guns!
Because I got great smile
to my friends right here.
- [Host] I'm okay with
having Down syndrome.
- [Matthew] So I agree
here on this because
it makes me me and my
friends don't treat me
like I'm just some random
kid with Down syndrome.
I'm happy for who I am.
Sometimes my family, they
kind of baby me a little bit.
But if I'm with my friends,
they don't try to baby me as much.
And I'm happy for that.
So for that reason,
I'm happy because they're happy.
- Me having Down syndrome
is not really hard for me
and just being who I am,
it just makes me special.
- I
I am okay
to be Down syndrome
because I am not ashamed
of who I am and what I look
like because I am beautiful,
successful, business,
confident, career woman.
I am really strongly
agree about what I am.
And don't be ashamed.
- [Sean] I have down syndrome.
I love who I am
because I am really, really
thankful
to myself.
I love myself.
I love these guys that be my friends
have Down syndrome, they're
really attach to me.
Come here.
- [Matthew] I love to stay
out late with my friends.
I love partying my friends,
no matter what I do,
even though I have a disability,
I can still have fun!
No matter what.
- That's right!
- [Matthew] Yeah!
(cheering)
- My man!
(cheering and clapping)
That was not impossible, guys.
- [Everyone] Three, two, one, Jubilee!
(cheering and clapping)
(crosstalk)